i mean he's a seven foot one guy
that has a guard set skill
holmgren spinning down the lane against
nixon puts it in
we've got the number two and number
three picks covering each other at the
moment home grin against smith
and here it is at the top
smith pokes it away
one for nine here in the first half and
over five from distance he's struggling
obviously
holmgren against smith defends him
nicely on that spin move in the low box
that's on everything but make shots he's
rebounded the ball he's defended now
he's going to knock down that jumper
and he does what he does he attacks he
attacks the attacks he gets to the
offensive glass he pursues the
basketball and plays really hard
easton just gave it to nix who got
rejected they'll give it to holmgren
another rejection for the big man that's
three in this half and he's taking it
right off
you're in the third quarter he's like a
human backboard right here bam give me
that
[Music]
nice ball movement
and there it goes down for jabari smith
as you mentioned three-point game is
where he has to improve and he's got
three of them here tonight
three out of four home green against
smith
goes to the right shoulder and puts the
hook shot up and in your team i mean
this guy is a physical multi-positional
defender
good defense on jabari smith but a
better turnaround jumper hit by the
number three selection final two minutes
here in vegas
one more game to come we'll have the
pelicans and the blazers next another
block for chet holmgren